Most likely, the best answer for this, are the
individuals that share five shorter segments. Now this was
kind of a tough problem and you really could
have gone with either answer, depending on how long, the
long segment is between those shared individuals. For the
single segment to be ranked higher than the five short
ones it would have to roughly be about five
times bigger than any of the short segments by themselves.
Assuming that they're all about the same size. Identity
by decent or IBD detection algorithms have a threshold
from which they consider a segment to be long
enough to be reported as Identity by Decent. So the
single segment would have to be pretty big. Now,
due to the fact that recombination occurs on every chromosome
in each generation, it's unlikely, very unlikely that a
long segment would be transmitted along one chromosome and nothing
on the others. But, how unlikely this is depends on the size of the segment.
Either way, if you were to see
a difference or comparison like this, you definitely
have to go back, examine your code
and think about the genetics behind what's going
on to best represent the outcome that should
be true. Computational biologists are really smart people.